now
there was this one pupil samuel leeds
and i'll get
him to describe what kind of a kid he
was but he has found now he's an adult
he's found an extraordinary way of
thanking his teacher so samuel leeds
joins me now samuel thank you for your
time
it's an absolute pleasure trish thanks
for having me on the show
samuel so what were you like as a kid
at school
well as a kid i had a very short
attention span i do suffer with adhd
also dyslexia
and i wasn't very good
as a kid at all
i went to a very small school and i sat
on a special needs desk um
and
i didn't really think there was much
hope for me in life at all but there was
one teacher called mrs haysmith that was
one of the only teachers that was always
really nice to me and she seemed to see
something that the others didn't um and
how was she just tell me samuel how how
was she
you know i'm guessing you were a
difficult kid
you know
from an adult's point of view
yeah definitely i i was often getting
detention and
even even suspended at one time i got
suspended from the school for a week not
for anything really malicious or really
bad it was just because i was so bored
in school i used to get into trouble
flick glue
i just did not like school at all
yeah but mrs haye smith how was she
different to you how did she tell me
about some of the things she did or said
that that
made her stand out from the rest
well for a start she seemed to actually
like me like you you kind of know if
someone doesn't like you and kids aren't
stupid and if they just talk about you
in the staff room and
it roll their eyes
you almost live up to that whereas with
mrs hay smith i used to always be really
good in her class because i thought well
she likes me and i don't want her to
stop liking me so i think for a start it
was the fact that she just seemed to
like me but also she used to say to me
oh you're going to be so successful when
you when you're a man you know when
you're an adult you're going to be oh
i'm so excited about your future and i
thought at the time i thought it was
really weird but i almost felt like i
wanted to live up to the belief that she
had in me even though i didn't have that
belief in myself at the time
yeah so i'm going to fast forward
was she right
well i mean success is very
subjective but i've been very successful
in business and i've gone on to become a
multi-millionaire i've got a very large
property portfolio i restore buildings i
build houses from scratch i've got a
castle that i own a grade two listed
castle in in budaly and i'm happily
married with three absolutely beautiful
children um so i think she probably was
right
whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa so how did you get
from that kid who couldn't sit still who
had you know was really behind the eight
ball as you said had dyslexia adhd
because this is a powerful message for
any other kid who's been labeled with
those things or been told they have
those
conditions how did you get from that to
where you are now
so when i was at school i believed that
there was two options you could either
go down the academic route and go to
university or the second option was you
could become like my dad was a gardener
when i was at school so i thought i
could become do something practical with
my hands maybe a builder and i wanted to
be when i was a kid i aspired to be a
dustbin man because i thought
you know i'll be good at that i am hard
working and i'm i'm fit and able and i
like being outside um what i didn't
realize there was there was a third
route which was entrepreneurship and i
think schools a lot of schools don't
teach
kids about money about finance about on
about being a business owner and when i
left school at 16
i read a book by a guy called robert
kiyosaki who now i actually know um but
it wasn't rich dad
and that book was all about money and it
was about passive income and real estate
and i just thought you know what i
failed in school
i could become a dustbin man or a
plumber or a plasterer but why don't i
just pursue this and i started going to
business events and learning about
property and investment and i just put
my absolute all into it and um and over
time i became a letting agent i became
an estate agent i bought my first house
as a teenager and over the years
just started accumulating properties um
and then when they went up in value i
refinanced them and bought more and
pulled investors in and i just got
really good at it and i think that it's
really important for me now to
teach kids that actually it is possible
to be a business owner it is possible to
be an investor so what part of my
mission now i'm actually i've got a
charity
and we're we're in the process of
planning with the ugandan government
about building schools and teaching kids
about that i've said i'll pay for the
buildings as long as you let me have an
input in the school curriculum because i
want kids wow
wow so so tell me i mean this and you
say this started with miss um mrs hay
smith
having belief in you and telling you
that you could be successful so i've you
know that that's kind of corny thing on
the first day of school you take an
apple for teacher they used to say oh
you here in america they give their
teachers presents you know to to thank
them quite rightfully for the work
they've done
what present did you give
mrs haysmith
so what i didn't realize was i didn't
realize that teachers weren't paid very
well and i'd never realized that a lot
of my teachers actually were
some of them were on the bread line and
mrs hasting was someone that i always
loved and when i left school i had a
fondness for her and when i started
learning about money and i set up a
business
i then stayed in touch with her and
seeing how her life was so different
from my life i was buying nice houses
going on nice holidays she couldn't
afford to do that
um a lot of felt a little bit i thought
that it wasn't really fair that she was
so
poor and on the literally couldn't
afford to um you know was struggling to
keep up with a mortgage and she lost her
job as a teacher she was made redundant
and she and she rang me up and said how
disappointed she was with her pension
and she asked me if i could help her and
i ended up spending a lot of time i like
we changed roles and i became mrs hay
smith's teacher
in business and i helped her
get on the um you know get on the
investment ladder and now she owns a
string of properties and she
relies off of to live she she gets paid
full-time she gets paid to be a
full-time property investor and she's
now um a really good friend of mine
she's come out to africa with me to help
with my charity works in in zambia and
uganda and we're really good friends and
she's now financially independent and
it's just the best that i can repair oh
samuel i love gosh did we need to hear
that story today i love that i love that
i love how it comes full full circle
so you so you're basically your message
to to kids out there who kind of feel
they're on the scrap heap and i love
that you say
i i so passionately believe we funnel
too many children into university in
higher education i think there's a lot
of them who don't need to be there who
buckle under the stress and have all
sorts of mental health situations
because basically that's not where their
heart lies but they think it's that or
as you said being a dustbin man or
something else that there's a middle
path so
um we're going to take we're going to
take a a quick break but afterwards i
think which is what is really powerful
is what message you would have to young
people who are kind of
at that crossroads at the moment
thinking where to go from now i'm
talking to samuel leeds who repaid his
teacher the one teacher that had belief
in him when he was a a kid there with
adhd and dyslexia and you know a little
bit disruptive i suppose you could could
label him but one teacher really told
him you can go far and um indeed he did
he's a millionaire property owner and he
thanked teacher by uh helping her create
a portfolio where she is now not just a
friend but she she owns her own
properties and earns her own living
samuel one of the things that as i said
before just before we took that quick
break that resonated with me is that
there's there does seem to be doesn't
matter this thing either you go to
university either you're academic or
you're kind of
going to manual labor there's a whole
world in between what would you say to
kids who don't want to go to university
don't particularly want to to
you know just don't know where they're
going what what sort of things should
they be considering
well i think
it's important to know that there is
another way and that is to be an
entrepreneur to be a business owner um i
mean
you go to school to learn how to get
good grades so that you can then get
into university so that then ultimately
you can get a job and the reason for a
job is to make money and you can skip
you can skip the job part and you can go
straight into the well let me just study
money and and learn how to make money so
i think there's certain kids that i see
today and they stand at a mile because i
can relate to them where they are doing
things like paper rounds and washing
cars um you've got an entrepreneurial
spirit to make money what i would say is
maybe consider um
consider going down the business route
because there is a third way and and a
lot of people that are successful in
business started out like richard
branson he had dyslexia as well
just because you might not be good in
school doesn't mean that you won't be
successful in life